hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar recent progress in cellular
medicine with a nod to precision
medicine I in Christina mihalik of lab
roots and I'll be moderating the session
today's educational web seminar is
presented by Lowry the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
to learn more visit la Bruce com let's
get started you can post questions to
the speakers during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click on your green
tea laneige button at the lower left of
the presentation window questions will
be answered after the presentation to
enlarge the sponge window click on the
screen icon is a lower right hand corner
of this slide window if you experience
technical problems seeing or here at the
presentation just click on the support
button down at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the screen this is
an educational webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credit after
the webinar is over please click on the
CT button located in the bottom left
hand corner of your web page and follow
the process with painting your credit it
is my pleasure to now for this today's
speaker judges two skulls PhD donner
professor of science and professor of
chemistry emeritus such an two skulls is
done a professor of clients america's
princeton university distinguished
adjoint professor in the department of
physics in biology at Temple University
distinguished scientists at secret on
LHS entry and today he is presently
shared senior grantee of the erc in the
Faculty of Medicine at the University of
food na Italy his career has been in
unusually long length of time and and
and and equally unusually broad range of
subject he has developed instrumentation
in mass spectroscopy got discussed in
the tree cross molecular beam staggering
clusters formation and spectroscopies
surface model layer grazing incident
x-ray scattering super fluid helium
Acropolis Melissa manipulation of vital
melt on my bio molecules final molecular
interaction at the name of scale in
medical and medical abandoned
diagnostics kieta group of collaborators
have recently patented a method to count
circulating tumor cells cells based on
the measurement of the metabolism every
cell isolated in a droplet of blood of
several people eaters when the droplets
results to become acid that indicates
the presence of cancer cancer cells he
has received several recognitions the
hearse top prize the gold medal of honor
of telling chemical society the ben
franklin medal for physics two honorary
doctorates the divided prize of the acs
the pilot rise of the aps and the
whooping can't award of the OSAA he is a
fellow of the aps o SI in the royal
society of the UK and the royal discuss
a memorial science academy of the
netherlands he has published about 300
papers in peer-reviewed journals and has
been quoted by his colleagues across
only nineteen thousand times his age in
bed 273 while I 10 index is 2 24 he has
supervised the adding hundred PhD
students an unusually high percentage of
which now both positions of
responsibility and academia and research
it is my pleasure to introduce professor
skulls professor called the floor is
yours thank you for your kind
introduction now it is going to
fertilize please the talk will be about
asian probation single-family scene will
ania precision medicine of cancer
[Music]
commission statement of precision
medicine initiative treats to enable a
new era of medicine to research
technology and politics and power
patients searches providers to work
together toward development in civilized
in edirect treatment the stately smells
like politics will it become very far
however is useful to take it as a
starting point to research and to ring
her about the subject in ad attainment
but excludes on the successes of
anything a biochemist mainly due to the
product nanotechnology feeding to single
cell analysis and other factories
[Music]
precision it is a medicine and
personalized medicine maybe two terms
will be used interchangeably so far
however have opposed to grab the chance
to existence of two terms and define the
same thing this thing is using amounted
to really personalized cancer medicine
can be taken to pass because certainly
will be based cleansing you see if it is
work relationship to wipe out the
advantages of official drug use which is
a classical now technology using more
less amount of drugs of the less
expensive but very clear specializing
treatment will be certainly more expense
involved before wiping out the damage to
the lamb instead casino medicine instead
of having ambition of chakra follow its
expression which we have ambition of
Holy Father away satisfied group of
patients for instance phenotype you can
come onto all say and patients suppose
you have a cause of patients or a
thousand you can sort out the phenotype
of 900 or 800 77 number of them as a
comic aerotek the address that take the
cells from the patient's treat them and
its treatment okay you can have the
mission if the patient rolls with it
after that let's wait Dex the phenotype
is a less sure way to cook chili
individuals of course it was the only
chance we have to for instance out of
thousand patients you can refer no type
comma about 150 make it to four
cylinders not work or an attorney for
ninety only because
the shuttle differences later on 11
doctors also at they determine also they
have common oh there is also the cure
for instance you can Evan celeb changing
the DNA chalk opinion DNA will make
however important for the Pyxis and it
before environment exchanges on the
patients that will make a different
outcome we have to postpone that sort of
differences to later if we can to ninety
percent of patients always tripping
outside will be a great success hold for
the Meccans therefore I see the medicine
will be successful but before going to
every leg and feel that we came to an
agreement reached an o-type read
sometimes just later on next doing the
rest of my talk I'm going to need two
examples of what I'm talking about so
far one taking the CPC's secreting cells
tumor cells in the peripheral blood and
counting them and rapidly and then
increase or decrease will be a function
of universes reading the literature
function of the progress in the cure
sickness therefore we can use this
counting security in the picture mode
and being useful to Michael therapy
second example will be actually going to
this cell and calcific I to get the
phenotype common participation
we started from one type of cancer then
breast tumor cancers and then go into
that with only sample small number of
sample patient will be about something
critical 60 it is no metal convenient
deep but I will make it later on how the
matter will be squeezed up eventually in
short time for now but first what we
learn slowly within pepper a machine to
machine disease sell separately and
therefore this is them take time to get
to a demonstration of the health of
CDC's secret to have so if you example
with a ranger for to understand what i
mean by curing a pharaoh type instead of
two official individual 52 ambitious
might be the quiet make a distinction
between specialized and precision
medicine interesting every feedback the
decisions i think is amazement and
literature before okay now that we've
got our two different today how did they
have the clink you have to go to Venice
32 more cancer for instance and and you
started therapy chicon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay this therapist I could redefine
timeline when the first character came
without the psychic pass and but one
week after that you need to recreate
eight weeks or shock system or any
covers the start is working or not to
count instead to michelle's in the
peripheral blood in case of the keys of
those can give an idea if the clerk is
working or not it's not working you
change it or you continue the rate
increase in the quality of life of the
patient as mean and if we working
anywhere you have confirmation one week
in a few doses or the series right click
when your allergy coming out and people
resort many case increases the wrong
time to wait you know i have c disease
and cancer therapy so best directors
process campus technology available
everywhere quite clearly dynastic is a
quick link in cancer care poor poor
screaming and thirty direction on campus
not very present to make medical campus
and in ocean decide about the progress
of the verbiage all do or not
[Music]
can't do much ask and vistas being very
very sensitive she's been difficult
because typically recognizes crack he
says you have to to you have to count
them and to find and pushed to find them
you have to find like a leading edge
tech basically because it went into the
ninth self as cancer typically included
the red blood cells with screw those 110
to the 50 100 60 per million or is it
they be probable detection but she's
been shown in the detector already using
a machine very vexing the only machine
is the FDA approval that is one to 10 to
the feast where 75 centimeter robot
present then take a group velocity
position about the survival of this
patient this more then then 160 per
square centimeter inside 573 option then
the tradition is poor so it can add this
test the resistance of drugs developing
the mutation coming all the
particularity that cancers have it makes
life so difficult for the toxic agents
can be bypassed by this message because
quiet it is a lifetime is time-sensitive
quarter of efficiency methods
literature there is you might go for so
family was the first important of this
cannot be predicted et over the CDC is
done many other photo server and agreed
to this in this sense you can now talk
about precision medicine because you can
take that particular class of patients
respond in the trail and treat them down
in this way is itself a bikini in the
browser location you can ever good hope
good oaks for the future if they are
increasing all the many same therefore
the prophecies bed and your skin therapy
you can say that innovation weeks 12
weeks they will increase eight to ten
weeks is enormous through use imaging a
way to protect cancer because the gold
standard in the field is very cushy more
the citizens united using magnetic email
sensing to the antibodies linked to the
magnetic nanoparticles brilliant camp
have selected account only peculiar
cancer cells but we know this because of
exterior two men within climber
transition schedule says cannot be
counted in this way and I realize this
problem stay in the second part of the
talk
[Music]
it's go to metastatic tumors I started
to mosar the main idea of death in
cancer they can difficulty for a survey
two more and we make our cars are even
more mortality is to all the countries
as you can change the consequence of the
therapy can become attracted to therapy
taking refuge from the definition
patient very difficult to sometimes
negative consequence the brain or
preservatives when it's not
accessibility and therefore need show
coverage for for diagnostic cancer you
can the CDC's we in at my group have two
students fabula be interpreters come up
we met we will be better than most for
existing quickly to the proposed to me
use metabolism as a biomarker for cancer
it's my big surprise no one is
profitable to screen disrespect so we
started like paper work for what is a
time with professional three years ago
first of the heart is recovered
indicated air
so my boy effective unknown you know in
a cancer cells it will cause
metabolizers into lactic acid I think I
in both the cells in the environment
sounded why in EM you know my selfie
because generate actively therefore
doesn't suffice imbalance the ridge
effect which is very well known
establish 36 th 0i Bible and we can
decide affecting well-known poisonous
environment around two more you can see
it but you cannot take anything that
entertaining that type of a physical it
was more the blood flow dilute phase
factor and and never sleep with danger
if you take any chances yes rate with to
interpret of water and then you Floyd in
Asheville took to sugar I'm telling the
truth i will be missing self watching a
proton pump you from the total out
that's right and environment on the
serving the Cassini pending of the
amount is when they take a self of 10
pic elitist something smaller changes in
the fifties I think it takes a levanta
cola but the size is a the mall yourself
not just a pickle eater and therefore
you can take a droplet in time from
other campuses volleyball cell may be
less healthy that show you we do the
following excellent value the type
little scrap and Cygnus the high school
sometimes time has touched them to open
i'm sorry wish okay the Virgin crucible
a machine if you text page changes
inexorable single solid now so you can
calculate every single droplet
and then with very few drop it contain
yourself while trying to make my
constant ammeter in 50 micron chocolate
cell but if volume with system emsco
will be honest I'm charges and all right
going up to detect a big change HD djs
go to the air and education of the
rivalry fire so a comparison here with a
very big machine now a Michael it may be
the same your group booking expression
and to add a surface of cells can we do
commit bit of all differences in pecos
often special attention a La Petite
yourself only can look all label
spectrum havoc every time yourself on
becomes acidic the into exceptions that
share iterations of coffee illegally
antibody by making patio fixes itself
and clear them basically and we enable
the comics enable sterilized anniversary
could be used for genetic purposes after
that the cosmic I 10 american rejects
and additional more important element
relative to important pushes exactly
accreditation blood you put the plug
into it nyquil environment on the
microscope and razor
[Music]
I got seeds of the moving image I mean
to make she developers moving any case
you can imagine that they were
destroying the simply exploring emerged
and is Mike emotionally to be informed
tens of it move down incubation time is
limited to 70 centigrade and the doctors
are collected in then if you see in this
example Sheriff's Office have been
collected one of them contains a cancer
cells and it is ribeiro there and the
process is coming out of there because
means that the environment is silly as
if I'd by they always held back even
this one where is to sell the effective
the affinity of the doctor see a pump of
a gamma the pressure pump in which
really secret and you she adopted moving
in they move down even when his doctor
go very fast to the phone wallets out of
a second drop it if you looking
millisecond told them of course to this
sacred gear relation can be right down
onto the sample and have used a special
method to pitch that if one goes up they
go down them sorry the civic visual
change the opposite remains yeah we can
break free first machine by by having
this peak in the control environment
where we change the pH always causes of
it
coming to see you know this inhale you
know I'm probably welded the pieces of
it you can see there from to beat rush
meeting message it took exchanges and
yes if Tingy kills the features of the
increase and the conviction call be very
good you can see there on the Left I i
I've hired all them holes like and we
can take cell line tour drive should not
get a cancer cell you can't decide what
is it from a cell culture came spiking
to the process she became the detective
please indeed is she the professional
[Music]
okay the other is sample whitewater only
you will see anything there if you had
breast cancer line mba mb 231 the
plaintiff of point where the city
increases on the axis x axis decided
drop it but relevant to take any size
their english in typical en center of
the side water bottle and yourself the
end result the two peaks jamaican is a
pier and you can take em VA and big 453
birth certificate in oma and your plan
to resolve their HT colorectal cancer
can join adenocarcinoma again spike
compression to show in the polls
confirming privilege and you can protect
them quite good quite a meal sometime
you fear of certification of viable
cells
can we talk about this perhaps later on
during the talk to see how much time
respond to the machine it you expose the
GPA changes the sugar for different I
amount means to be a kind of amused
excretion all right we went to
asymptotic region you should longer we
add to the final analysis there for ten
years are sufficient even less probable
the machine built my skype samples now
take you all blood I'm expecting MBA and
be 468 shared culture you consider the
plaintiff signal a situation when the
exhaust size or move to absorb to
contain any facts 10 and the
verification of purchase group from some
time advances impurity resulting says
they drop it changes create in time but
then if you go sell it we examine every
whe photographic machine is no less that
if schools onclick eliminated then we
are
[Music]
anted on of light bulb and then not know
it all now citizens of it and maybe for
465 and they erupt so this really is her
Spanish we can see we can get me wrong
because L Sedona and no signals were
spiked Roosevelt you're not a finger if
you're patient sample external missed
iceberg no signal MDA spice and cause
I'm ecstatic patient we see us many
dollars were change change them they're
filthy typically we had too many
coprophagia simply respectful to the
Vegas machine but that's a different
result the Creator we are chillin like
three speak and waitress caution as a
family basic imma position George
present and we can see that you lose the
figure where is a very camera Marcus I
on the cell the mystical epithelial
position therefore cannot be detected
Israelis so you should always see more
debate exists or same materials with
anything like between cancer cell and
we're closer Spidey God we can affect on
the self-involved sucks dynamos you look
there sample she's batters for Kansas
online education the egg dishes all the
holes life and my students and co-worker
and they recent quite a big foolishment
they're not like to speak in public
about it they've been conducting
compared with physics and we love the
sort of allowed because now we never
better to own it offers many Spanish
shells
m and has those being signed first
edition to therapy single resource
solution genetic profiles of the tours
and headed changing in time and it
changes literature to hotel and pickled
sausages or funny parallel
soul/self/psyche decide by the tower say
instead in particular we need to compare
our results with those canadian about
skype different responses indicated as
good as means that she has called him no
answer c'mon Wendy Davis machine he has
no he's messing with no joke about
reverse innovation Holland in his crew
is broken can people in my group I am a
calculator hospital to the necessarily a
photocall party I've ever been in a
telephone and about the table phonies
work then go to discuss expects actually
CBC's we could not do it the same level
of separation trailer chief now like
with a little in the dropper methanol
because then enough sauce them develop
certain flavors are starting now and a
new new great emotional like we machine
between the very shortly but if you use
very covetous incomplete yesterday
anticipation germany references post
lots of them we also time for this but
you can then get an idea about so let's
go to work when you're good faster
and it was there was it because now okay
maybe here were funny the fall asleep
type they can detect and count the city
she XO comparable to cannot do this is
the array itself and shorten without
damaging it the characterizes can change
evaluate the matter so take for them to
arrive to em to a position yourself one
day so you can see this rate it a
patient Leland two weeks to do patient
also do some are a one-year working 650
patient zero to work for having clear of
the issue but Scotia then they can take
the potato market in economics is she be
fortified helps set has been clear Bible
into the parade to remember them and any
separate them and show you the job next
here you have
ok that is coalition of the new guy
opens oven then this vision time on
Marcus the red ones Bettina Marcus green
ones cd45 marker and undefended for
Avila corner you can see their selves
which are both missing cameras and the
pedia markers them and always redirected
in CC p.m. if I mention that they can
believe it defiled by the pelvis machine
they and Austria for the job they can do
so I I just fell in detail this way a
cannibal phony as come to some
conclusions
[Music]
[Music]
she's comparing with a first machine and
then she has a [ __ ] between the case but
illogical features consider listing with
462 populations going to make sure you
next slide let her to fuzzy diseases
breast cancer expand the number of age 8
i'ma send this case you can recalculate
counting of the house for the Angry Men
today with a baby huh she vomited is
high number of to the sense I am not
selling again here is a good case for
comparable related machine living it all
the kids where the comparability
resolution is good shifting higher
number within yourself lower number make
a massage magni high number of seniors
number organizational site is 150
clients it is marginally higher number
of negative said mobile clinic Marcus
what he found were unexpected to her to
us all affected if we sell all
traditions the apt very famous
remarkable psychic cells and it's
totally self in colleges of the present
people the big clear and octopus figure
yes it
this is an opportunity bury her physical
even the government cares a lot visible
so quinta presented is million
kilometers if it is smaller fifty
percent survival rate is very good my
planet is innocent translate because
very well I clear distinction between
survival rate education so this is a
very dispersibility five short life is
in kemah like a tree like a fish as well
as a commercial something a second on
the Gulf downstream analogous she see
the progression grab estimating a
deposition person you have come because
of their association between to Nevada
logical features don't need to be
confirmed two thousand numbers as I of
course faculty research question is kind
of oxygen to the college where survival
number since especially Carol Marcus
will be productive flexible well
survival and progression-free survival I
[Music]
ok low number of internal market quality
is good for a quick-fire
[Music]
in power now is it is very compelling
research appreciative inquiry I love to
i'm going and then you generation
sequencing he has been cut out to study
recent drug him connecting with AC
result number krishna 3d home on 6 230
and get built a recently Kristen and I
to go to sell this co workers for this
tag work and the need to serving middle
group in commercial Thomas Canada latest
economic data I forget extra special
Michaela before you can walk the walk
this is report major part was very
comparable a sexist machine windows
because the mark Elizabeth oh [ __ ]
internal loop in our group in chico
buarque simulator brandy and to
Jerusalem in equal economic Aragon to
finish through the nominal pudding where
is cookies ahead and my wife is we get
support with my age no CDs you can see
in the talkative type who have taken
care of okay thank you so long
[Music]
chaffee professors schools for your
informative presentation a quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply Tyson in the Q&A
box found by clicking on the green Q&A
button as the lower left of the
presentation window professor schools
will insert as many questions as time
permits all right let's hop right in the
first question today professor skulls
ask in your opinion is the distinction
between personalized and precision
medicine is necessary as I introduce it
[Music]
it is essential to make assistant work
for specification of patients where
hundreds or ten patients are on the same
paradise can be seated seemingly and
therefore I hope survival together right
really pressure on allison is far away
em but and i don't want it failure to do
lyrics rhyme anything coming to the way
of this procedure medicine can't use it
for phenotypes and air pipes common that
i think it's possible but of course we
exclude now in fact is my personal
unified language engine
thank you for your answer our second
question asked is the metabolism of a
valid criteria to locate in sort CT she
fell business was known in a sense
without our machine that count has one
by one the tablet leaves is being a
criteria to study cancer already in bulk
but then went we doing to ourselves and
machine is very type of cancer Tessa so
far too much health respond defying the
environment and the metabolically
responsible for work they do it would
make us to to pursue for I have taken so
far yes yes thank you it appears that we
have one last question for today this
question as can metabolism be useful in
studying or practicing spell medicine in
other illnesses yes we hope very much so
Michigan is America profiles feeling
around study expand the study of
automotive kereta bookshelf some critics
praising we can get convicted
[Music]
additionally nose being is typically
then the erotic dramatic actress
activities can quickly great yourself
that you provoked
we'll attended end that only lasted
little prognosis but three highly self
on my one it's as a percentage of them
to show features that can be taking
proportional to lane to the
diagnostically sickness hey let's go
case major colors will be done in this
case because they are not good
diagnostic criteria one steady criteria
for attack critias islamic judges only
on the print on your pain and your joint
to the phone and your girl mythology and
then but there's no forget the melting
away the pain disappears before there is
American working but his number of
fairly pleases and Daniel 11 metro one
we have been fighting this battle work
present we are very beginning stage at
the Polo single shot but i think if you
could make them w-well from this case
thank you as we don't have any further
questions professor school thank you for
your time today we like to leave us with
any final comments and thank you for the
opportunity to present this work and
define as an irony for the premaxilla
thank you i would like to once again
thank professors goals for his
presentation I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and thank
the libraries for today's educational
web cast this webcast can be viewed on
demand through a 20-17 Ian library
spoilers via email when is available for
read
play we encourage you to share that
email with your colleague Dumanis
today's live event I'll see you next
time here at leverage com thank you and
goodbye